[Music]
it may seem like everyone wants to be a
superhero these days but a few stars
have still
tried to steer clear of the world of
comic book movies here are a few of the
actors who said no
when dc came calling leonardo dicaprio
has spent the vast majority of his life
in hollywood
but before he achieved global fame in
james cameron's 1997 epic titanic
warner brothers approached him to star
in joel schumacher's batman forever
seeing how things turned out it's
probably fair to say that turning them
down was the right choice
the studio wanted dicaprio for the part
of dick grayson also known as robin but
dicaprio just wasn't feeling it
contrary to rumors dicaprio has said he
never screen tested for the role
though he did talk to schumacher he told
shortlist i had a meeting with joel
schumacher
it was just one meeting and no i didn't
end up doing it
despite meeting with the director
dicaprio said he never even wanted the
role he explained
as i recall i took the meeting but
didn't want to play the role
joel schumacher is a very talented
director but i don't think i was ready
for anything like that
the role ended up going to chris
o'donnell but interestingly
robin wasn't the only superhero role
hollywood offered dicabrio
sony pictures approached him to play
spider-man for director sam raimi but as
with robin he said he just wasn't ready
to put on a suit
at this juncture in his oscar-winning
career it seems unlikely he's in any
rush to change his mind
warner brothers have been trying to get
a green lantern film off the ground for
well over
a decade before martin campbell directed
the character's first live-action outing
in 2011. the studio approached kevin
smith in 1997 to write a script for the
film but he turned down the offer
feeling he wasn't the right fit for the
job
then renowned director quentin tarantino
received an offer to helm the project
but he also turned it down feeling he'd
outgrown
his adoration for comic books when the
studio finally settled on a director and
screenwriter they began their search for
hal
jordan while ryan reynolds ultimately
got the part he wasn't always a top
contender
warner brothers approached bradley
cooper chris pine
justin timberlake and sam worthington
who all either turned the role down
or were rejected by the studio another
one-time contender was madman star jon
hamm he recalled to gq
they came after me pretty hard for green
lantern but i was like meh that's not
what i want to do
never say never but these aren't the
kind of movies i'd like to go and see
they don't make the kind of movies i'd
like to see anymore
nostalgia it's delicate
but potent pierce brosnan
has had a hugely prolific career but his
tenure as the slick mi6
spy james bond will undoubtedly remain
its highlight
at one point however brosnan had the
opportunity to star in a comic book
movie that probably would have not only
dashed his chances to be
bond but also changed the landscape of
the superhero genre
just imagine for a second that brosnan
not michael keaton played batman in tim
burton's 1989 film
sounds crazy but there was a chance of
it happening in a reddit ama
brosnan admitted to meeting burton for
the role he wrote
yes i did i went and met with tim burton
for the role of batman
but i just couldn't really take it
seriously any man who wears his
underpants outside his pants
just cannot be taken seriously that was
my foolish take on it
it was a joke i thought but how wrong
was i brosnan stressed the fact that he
doesn't hate batman he just couldn't see
himself playing the character in a movie
he wrote don't get me wrong because i
love batman and i grew up on batman
as a kid in ireland we used to get our
raincoats and tie them around her neck
and swing through the bicycle shed
however it appears that brosnan's
hesitation with batman led him to james
bond
and thus gave him the defining role of
his career
so it's not all bad there aren't many
actors more highly regarded than anthony
hopkins
known to many as hannibal lecter from
the silence of the lambs and its sequels
hopkins was also up for a few early
roles in the world of comic book movies
but declined to take them before michael
kane boarded christopher nolan's batman
begins as bruce wayne's butler alfred
pennyworth nolan reportedly offered
hopkins the role
he turned it down however for reasons
unknown interestingly despite reportedly
being turned down for the role of mr
freeze and joel schumacher's batman and
robin
hopkins maintained his interest in dc
movies
not long after turning down the role of
alfred pennyworth and batman begins he
finally joined the dc universe as jorel
and jj abrams and brett ratner's
superman flyby things didn't work out
though and the project mutated into
brian singer's superman returns
he told mtv news i was going to do the
movie with brett
and i don't know what happened there was
some political movement i think brett
was out of line with something and they
said thank you very much
i never heard from brett since then but
i was all set to do it
hopkins finally found his comic book
home in 2011 when he took the role of
odin
in thor a role he has returned to many
times since
jude law may be an excellent actor but
he's not really a huge movie star
after the disastrous critical and box
office performance of sky captain in the
world of tomorrow
law was probably nervous about
headlining another action franchise
especially when the character in
question was the greatest superhero of
them all
on the late show with stephen colbert
law revealed that director brian singer
offered him the role of the man of steel
for 2006's superman returns
i have this picture of that of me in
that costume
you know on posters all around the world
and i was like no way
law turned down the role which went to
the relatively unknown brandon ralph
after superman returns lukewarm
reception the series was rebooted with
law's fellow brit henry cavill taking
the lead
i'm an englishman and i felt like you
know i don't know it just didn't seem to
fit and i was always worried about the
unit the outfit and
i just didn't fancy it law presumably
had no such qualms about the wardrobe
attached to the character of yon rock
the kree warrior he played in 2019's mcu
blockbuster captain marvel
movie stars don't come much bigger than
will smith and this was especially true
in the mid 2000s so it seemed natural
that he'd end up taking a part in a
superhero movie and according to smith
himself
he wasn't just offered any superhero
role but the mightiest of them all
superman apparently brian singer asked
smith to play the big blue boy scout in
superman returns but smith didn't even
need to see the suit
he rejected the part because he didn't
want to repeat what was then his biggest
career mistake
smith told mtv there is no way i'm
playing superman
because i had already done jim west in
wild wild west and you can't be messing
up white people's heroes
in hollywood you mess up white people's
heroes in hollywood you'll never work in
this town again
smith would go on to play his own
superhero in hancock and would later
join the dc expanded universe as
deadshot imagine living in an alternate
universe where heath ledger played
batman and christian bale played the
joker well it's not really that far
fetched
in 2005 ledger was hollywood's gravely
voiced king of cool
while bale was most known for playing
the maniacal murdering psychopath
patrick bateman in american psycho
and according to the dark knight
trilogy's director christopher nolan
it was almost ledger not bale who donned
the cape and cal
in an interview with the daily star
nolan revealed that he offered the part
of batman to ledger but was turned down
nolan said he was quite gracious about
it but he said i would never take a part
in a superhero film
thankfully ledger eventually changed his
mind presumably after he saw batman
begins and realized nolan was going for
a grittier
more realistic take on the character
fortunately there were no hard feelings
on nolan's end as he clearly was a great
admirer of ledger's work
the dark knight would go on to be one of
the highest grossing movies of the
decade being the first film to earn over
500 million dollars domestically since
titanic
largely due to ledger's performance as
the clown prince of crime
ledger tragically died before the film's
release but his work won him his first
and only oscar it seems like everybody
was considered for the part of wonder
woman at some time or another though
it's doubtful many of the actresses
considered were ever formally approached
for the role
one actress who was approached and
turned it down was kate beckinsale
with her lead role as vampire death
dealer celine in the successful
underworld franchise
beckinsale would have been a perfect fit
for the amazonian warrior in the mid
2000s alas the most recent female
superheroes on film during that time
were halle berry and catwoman
jennifer garner in elektra and charlize
theron in eon flux
not the best track record and it sounds
like this proposed wonder woman vehicle
wasn't going to be much better
speaking in reference to 2017's wonder
woman beckinsale later told yahoo movies
the incarnations that i was seeing were
they weren't this one
but even if the script had been better
it sounds like beckinsale would have
been hung up by the same thing which has
always worried actors playing
superheroes
beckinsale explained i don't know if i
was desperate to be in a leotard
i'd already done the rubber trousers you
have to take in that you have a child at
some point and how much could you
possibly embarrass them
charlize theron wasn't up for the part
of wonder woman in the 2017 film but she
did
turn down a major role as wonder woman's
mother hippolyta
in an interview with andy cohen on watch
what happens live
theron explained she ended up in talks
for a part in the movie while it was
still in development but it wasn't the
one she expected
and i was like i just i'm not i'm not
familiar with it i don't really know
what it like mean
what is wonder woman do and my this
person said
no it's for wonder woman's mom theron of
course is only 10 years older than
wonder woman star gal gadot
despite wonder woman being directed by
patty jenkins who directed
charlize theron's oscar-winning turn in
2003's monster theron declined the part
which went to connie nielsen who was
about 19 years older than gadot
director zack snyder apparently felt
slighted when kristen stewart rejected
the role of lois lane in 2013's man of
steel
according to sources close to the
director he and his wife producing
partner deborah
met with stuart about playing the iconic
reporter while snyder was interested in
stewart however he apparently never
formally offered her the parts but
stewart made clear that she was not
interested
evidently surprising snyder stewart
herself had been caught off guard by the
blockbuster success of the twilight
films and the spotlight it put on her
personal life
especially her relationship with co-star
robert pattinson
stewart was still working on the
twilight series at the time and wanted
to focus on smaller
more independent films which man of
steel most definitely was not
snyder wasn't upset for long however and
soon hired a-lister amy adams for the
role but adams may have wished
she'd turned down the part two stewart's
focus on smaller films gave her career a
renewed vigor while snyder's dc
films started with poor feedback and
continued on a downward slide
maybe stewart ought to warn her x before
he puts on that cowl as the new batman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one